you know what it is is he tried to flip
it like not just him but people
everybody like a lot of people trying to
flip this race car thing right A lot of
people are trying to say that I'm a
visitor to hip-hop you know what I'm
saying and I don't have a right to speak
on certain things all right anybody
that's saying that you got it you got it
look I'ma take my glasses off you got it
you won you won
you won I'm a visitor to Hip Hop I'm a
visitor to Hip Hop so I'ma pack my [__]
and go respectfully all right but before
I pack my [__] and go I'm gonna take
some things with me that belong to
my my culture right okay so uh Nas Nas
Illmatic nice Illmatic right five mics
yeah yeah Miss info gave him those five
mics Miss info is a korean-american
woman Miss info gave him those five mics
I want those five mics back respectfully
so now
Illmatic ain't a classic no more
okay we're not gonna stop there I got
some other things I want to pack up with
me when I go all right
um
Pharrell Neptunes Neptunes Chad half of
chat half half half right here he's
happy yeah right right I need all of
that back too and half half like divorce
divorce half I need half of that right
so uh Snoop Dogg Beautiful
I just want you to know I needs that I
need half of that you know what I'm
saying Super Thug I need half of that
too you know what I mean I'm taking all
that with me too you know what I'm
saying oh I'm not done I'm not done
Wu-Tang Clan Ain't Nothing to [__] with
I need that too that name I need that
too Wu-Tang Clan we need that too
respectfully you know what I'm saying
into the 36 Chambers we need that too
respectfully you know what I'm saying uh
uh uh mystery is chess boxing
need that too need that too
there it is
I think that uh the people who leave
those comments though the visitor [__]
it's like it's so low it's like low
hanging fruit
to me the rate like Ray [__] and Hip-Hop
like I get sometimes like the low
hanging fruit is like when someone calls
me a culture vulture
like after I don't have them on my show
or they've DM me 10 times and I'm like
I'm just not into it you know your
[__] culture vulture I'm like I mean
all right dude you know like
does that make you feel better
you know yeah it says come on it's just
is is it is is is
that's weak man going with a race car
this week you know what I'm saying like
I understand like I understand that
people is like okay hip-hop is a black
culture and I'm not I'm not taking that
from the black people hip-hop is a Black
Culture but let me tip before but but
Hip Hop was what
hip-hop was made in New York [__]
City
New York City the Bronx hip-hop is a New
York culture before you say any of that
hip-hop is a New York culture because we
the ones New York was was the first ones
to do hip-hop it formulated in in New
York City the Bronx the Bronx the boogie
down it came from the Bronx right you
understand what I'm saying and I don't
know where you from if you ever been to
New York but New York is like this like
everything is on it's not like La where
everything is where the Asian people are
here black people were here Mexican
people here no New York is like these
people here right here right here you're
building your top of this building
everybody is on top of each other right
so if anything when hip-hop was was was
was made
everybody in a vicinity was around it
just five elements to hip-hop I bet you
all those people leaving comments on my
page soak them out I'm a visit to Hip
Hop y'all can't even name the five
elements to hip-hop this is true you can
you wasn't even alive when I started
listening to Hip Hop I started listening
to hip-hop in 1987. you were still in
your daddy nuts in 1987 coming on on my
page talking about I'm a visitor but
what the [__] is you talking about if
I'm a visitor hip-hop that logic that
you have because hip-hop was made by
black people right
and um hip-hop was made by black people
let me calm down a little bit hip-hop
was made by black people okay
me being an Asian-American man born and
raised in New York City around hip hop
since I was a kid 1987 was the first
year I was introduced to hip-hop right
if I'm a visit at hip hop being that I
was born and raised and I learned so
much in hip-hop and Hip-Hop was a part
of my life the only thing that's been a
part of my life for all those years of
my life right the only thing that I
still have something to do with is I
still that's still a part of my [__]
daily right if I'm a visit to Hip Hop
solely because I'm not black
then if we adopt that logic logic
Michael Jordan is a visitor to
basketball
white people invented basketball
so I mean
you telling me Michael Jordan is a
visitor to basketball LeBron James a
visitor basketball Muhammad Ali float
like a butterfly thing like a bee I'll
visit a boxing
the nerve
imagine a white person come out and say
man you guys playing basketball are
visitors to basketball it would be an
absolutely absurd thing if someone said
that for sure that'd be a ridiculous wow
but but
will be so I don't know what people be
thinking bro people would just be caught
up in their own thing they don't think
with logic let's think with logic we are
not in where I'm not from China I'm not
from Africa I mean I'm not from China
hip-hop was made not in Africa hip-hop
was made in New York city in America so
yes it was started by black people but
it's everybody in that vicinity was
affected by it immediately it spread
like it spread like a disease like it
was all over it was hip-hop was it
wasn't just black people listening to
hip-hop bro there's five elements to it
there was spent there was Puerto Ricans
doing break dancing there was people
doing graffiti Asian people doing
graffiti and it was also it was it was
all types of stuff going on so um
respectfully uh
shut the [__] up
well there you have it by the way some
of the best DJs ever are all Asian like
[__] man Qbert
Qbert is that guy DJ craze
so yeah there's some great some great
Asian DJs out there and and and for
people to try to paint the narrative
that I'm like
racist like bro I don't have our races
bone in my body bro like I came with
somebody today you know I'm saying
everybody at the piano I was constantly
with black people like you know I'm
saying like I don't have races I don't
have those Tendencies but I'm not gonna
stand down on [__] nobody's gonna strip
me of what I feel like is mine you know
what I'm saying so I'm not gonna allow
that no time nobody I'm not gonna do
that that's like me letting you take
something from me I die before I let you
take something from me facts we gonna
shoot it out before you take song from
me facts so that's what we gonna do I'm
not backing down bro never